so wie kommts heutigen sitzung heute
lernen sie endlich mal etwas physik
kennen moderne physik heute geht es über
albert einstein etwas über seine
spezielle relativitätstheorie
aber bevor wir dazu kommen müssen wir
noch mal ein bisschen wiederholen weil
seine theorie natürlich nur verständlich
ist vor dem hintergrund dieser theorien
die sie auch schon der letzten sitzung
teilweise kennen gelernt haben und ich
möchte noch mal ein bisschen wiederholen
also das hier ist heiser newton und er
hat eine schrift verfassten titel
mathematischen prinzipien der natur
lehre und darin hat newton sein begriff
der absoluten zeit entwickelt kann von
ihnen wie jemand noch mal sagen was man
nach noten unter der absoluten zeit
verstehen kann
hat jemand von ihnen ideen
wir haben wir uns versucht das
vorzustellen die absolute zeit
beim absolut was der gegensatz zu
absolut bezug auf die zeit haben sie die
ja genau
genau haben sie ein beispiel was dagegen
jetzt die relative zeit wäre genau also
zum beispiel die drehung der erde um die
sonne oder im video
die bewegung des uhrzeiger so kleinere
abgeschlossen einheiten
das ist für newton nur die relative zeit
und wir haben ja gesehen
die erde dreht sich ja nicht genau
innerhalb von einem jahr um die sonne
es ist ein bisschen paradox formuliert
wenn ich das so sage weil sie ja eine
auslenkung von fünf metern
mehr oder weniger hat pro jahr also die
variation von jahr zu jahr ist ungefähr
5 meter also wenn du jetzt hier
die sonne haben sonne und die erde dreht
sich darum
dann ist eben manchmal ist eben dann
eher die radios ein bisschen bisschen
vielleicht größere klein ja diese
differenziert sie ist dies minimal die
so gering die fällt praktisch gar nicht
ins gewicht werden wenn das jetzt hier
die erde ist die erde die sich um die
sonne dreht aber man konnte im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert ernst zeigen
dass diese unterschiedliche rotation als
diese unterschiedlichen radien die
minimal voneinander abweichen dass die
sich auf die länge des jahres auswirken
und zwar im schweiße millionste
stundenbereich weise wie viel der
wievielte bruchteil einer sekunde das
ist weil die erde sich rasend schnell um
die sonne dreht
die schule bewegt sich ja nicht sehr
langsam titel legt sich ja sehr schnell
und es sind minimale zeiteinheiten die
konnte man erst mit der erfindung der
quarzuhr richtig messen also ich
bestimmen
und jetzt ist es warm ist es jetzt
paradox wenn ich sage das jahr ist
unterschiedlich lang
warum ist diese aussage erst ein
bisschen seltsam wenn ich die
unterschiedliche länge des jahres mit
dem unterschiedlich großen radius der
umdrehung der erde um die sonne
begründet warum ist das jetzt mal
begrifflich erstmal paradox wenn ich das
so sagen
absolut richtig dass das so kann man es
sagen dass er sagt das ja ist einfach so
definiert und ich will es noch ein
bisschen anders formulieren wir sagen
einfach das jahr besteht in der zeit die
die erde braucht um die sonne zu
umdrehen und umkreisen und wenn sie
jetzt eben ein bisschen länger braucht
dann ist es ja halt ein bisschen länger
könnte man ja sagen sie merken also das
jahr ist eigentlich relativ zur bewegung
und das führt uns dann wieder zu
aristoteles zurück aristoteles hatte
wenn ich mich nicht irre kann man
darüber diskutieren dann eher nach
newton so ein relatives zeitverständnis
weil er die zeit zu erinnern die
bewegung gebunden hatte also
gleichförmige periodische abfolgen er
war davon ausgegangen wie ich das letzte
mal dass koalition sagte dass eben den
kosmos also das universum so
strukturiert ist dass es eben
gleichförmige bewegung und absolut
identische perioden voraussetzt und das
ist eben nicht der fall wie man jetzt
zeigen konnte was zum beispiel die
drehung der erde um die sonne anbelangen
also prima fazit könnte man sagen ja
aber ein jahr ist doch so definiert dass
es die zeit ist die die erde braucht um
einmal die sonne zum kreis als ein
bisschen paradox
wir definieren das jahr über die zeit
die die erde braucht um die sonne zum
kreisen und jetzt sagen wir plötzlich
nein das ist nicht genau ein jahr weil
sie braucht ja ein bisschen mehr strecke
die erde
manchmal um die sonne zum kreisen als
das jahr davor
aber ja ist doch geradezu definiert das
ist die zeit ist die erde braucht um die
sonne zu umrunden
da wird schon irgendwie paradox weil
dann fragt man sich ja an was messen
jetzt dann bitteschön die das jahr und
die zeit wenn nicht an der bewegung an
der zeit die die erde braucht um die
sonne zu umkreisen was ist denn der
maßstab wenn es jetzt doch nicht hier
die bewegung ist dieser diese diese
einheitlich bewegung woher nehmen wir
das dann ähnlich kann man sich natürlich
auch fragen mit der sekunde
da haben wir ja schon das letzte mal
darüber gesprochen dass das gemessen
wird über elektromagnetische strahlung
und wellen solche dinge genauso kann man
sich natürlich fragen ja woher nehme ich
denn jetzt die information was genau ein
meter ist was ein zentimetern ist also
sie sehen mit solchen maßeinheiten
würzen immer schwierig jedenfalls hat
man gezeigt dass eben hier gewisse
relativität gegeben ist die relativität
die natürlich albert einstein meint
einfach das eben natürliche bewegungen
im kosmos nie perfekt sind das sind
alles nur idealisierung wenn man genauer
hinschaut merkt man da gibt es immer
wieder
abweichungen was könnte denn der grund
sein dass hier manchmal die erde bis ich
einen größeren radius hat und deshalb
überlegen sie mal was du was könnte es
von grund geben
ich weiß nicht aber was wäre möglicher
grund
genau zum beispiel wer die sonne strahlt
ja ab energie also es könnte an der
sonne liegen noch mit der
anziehungskraft
das können natürlich auch darin ja genau
genau gravitation da könnt ihr irgendwie
ein himmelskörper mal hier seien jetzt
natürlich nicht im richtigen maßstab und
dann ist er mal hier und diese differenz
hier sorgt dafür dass hier andere
antritt cavitation verhältnisse
herrschen und dadurch wird eben die erde
mal aus ihrem normalen radius
ausgelegten 5 meter das kann die
millionen kilometern kann das hier sehr
eigenen eine verschiebung und hat das
einfluss darauf
die nal sie sehen alles hängt irgendwie
miteinander zusammen das ist schon klar
und jetzt wollen wir uns hier noch mal
kurz fragen was newton der absoluten
zeit versteht des hammels grad gemacht
als es einfach diese dauerhaft
gleichförmig verlaufen die grund zeit
könnte man sagen könnte auch sagen so
eine art hintergrund natürlich muss man
sich fragen wenn man jetzt sagt diese
absolute zeit ist dieser konstante
hintergrund dann scheint das der rede zu
widersprechen dass die zeit auch die
absolute zeit verrinnt oder verläuft und
sagt ja die absolute zeit verläuft
völlig gleichförmig aber wie kann sie
das tun wenn sie doch so eine art
konstanten hintergrund bildet muss sie
nicht um verlaufen zu können auch noch
so konstant wiederum gemessen werden an
einer anderen zeit die noch absolute ist
diese frage habe ich mir jetzt ein
bisschen gestellt wie kann man denn von
einem konstanten hintergrund sprechen er
verläuft das ist doch alles relativ er
verläuft nur bezogen wiederum auch was
antritt
wir lesen noch ein paar zitate das haben
wir schon uns überlegt wie sich das zum
zeitverständnis bei aristoteles und
augustinus verhält es ihnen hier zu kalt
bisschen kalt drinnen bin nicht jetzt
sagt hier zum beispiel juden in diesem
zitat
die absolute ware und mathematische zeit
verfliest an sich und vermögen ihrer
natur gleichförmig und ohne beziehung
auf irgendeinen äußeren gegenstand sie
wird so auch mit dem namen dauer also
wie kann die absolute zeit für fließen
er sagt sehr viel ist an sich also
absolut für sich nicht für etwas anderes
eine beziehung auf irgendeinen
gegenstand also die sie ist die zeit an
der eben andere zeiten gemessen werden
können
davon hebt diese andere zeit ab die
relative scheinbare und gewöhnliche zeit
ist ein viel bares und äußerliches
entweder genaues oder ungleiches maß der
dauer dessen man sich gewöhnlich statt
der waren zeit bedient wie stunde tag
monat ja das war das mit diesem jahr das
wurst den juden sicherlich auch der hat
es vermutet dass eben stunden tage und
monate nie ganz genau gleich lang sind
ne es gibt ja dann diese schaltsekunde
das ist schaltzeiten die man dann immer
wieder eingefügt hatte um eben diese
ordnung wieder her zu bekommen musste
sich da zusätzliche tricks bedienen um
diese illusion dieser völlig
gleichförmigen jahres bewegung
aufrechtzuerhalten
man muss das so ein bisschen nachhelfen
dem anwalt sekunde eingeführt hat
irgendwas anderes angefügt
man konnte es nicht anhand der
natürlichen bewegungen aufrechterhalten
es ist halt nicht wie bei wie
aristoteles denkt dass der kosmos
perfekt ist es gibt immer wieder
einflüsse die von ganz weit vorne kommen
können wir jetzt hier so ein stern oder
irgendwas massen masse die groß genug
ist um einfluss zu haben auf die
bewegung der erde
ich habe mich vor drei tagen mit einem
englischen philosophen unterhalten und
er meinte dann gegen albert einstein
gerichtet nein man kann dennoch so etwas
wie eine absolute zeit annehmen
das hatte mich aber nicht überzeugen
aber darüber müssen wir nochmal reden
jedenfalls ist die zeit nach noten
ähnlich zu verstehen wie der raum der
absolute raum
der ist sie ist auch der absolut raum
ist an sich ohne bezug auf etwas äußeres
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
es nicht nur so eine konstruktion der
gedanke des absoluten raum ist der
absolute zeit
ich meine ein argument ist natürlich um
bewegungen zu messen zu können
schnellere bewegungen langsame
bewegungen brauchen wir einen maßstab an
an dem wir das dann messen und das
mögliche kandidat wäre so was wie eine
absolute zeit absolut gleichförmig
verändernde zeiten
wir haben uns dazu vorgestellt im
letzten film in der letzten stunde dass
wir dieser kampf das ist halt diese drei
derzeit also diese dieser zeitstrahl von
einem journalistischen gesichtspunkten
betrachtet für den so was wie zukunft
vergangenheit und gegenwart keine rolle
spielen als es sowas einfach diese
zurzeit frei
mit einem früher oder später so was
haben wir hat eine richtung aber mehr
nicht einfach diese reine berei derzeit
so könnte man sich vielleicht die
absolute zeit vorstellen
vielleicht haben sie noch andere ideen
wie man sich die vorstellen könnte man
da hätten wir jetzt dann den verlauf wir
hätten jetzt da die bewegung drin also
es geht einfluss hat eine richtung und
das ist halt gleichmäßig wie sollen
zahlen strahl vielleicht wie so ein
zahlenspiel das hat er glaube ich schon
ontologisch gedacht also die zeit gibt
es hier als alle kosmologischen
angelegenheiten wie stern bewegungen und
bewegung der erde und der sonne
die hätte er ja auch nicht zur absoluten
zeit gezählt das wären ja alles nur
dinge der relativen zahlen ist einfach
es ist immer könnte es aber es ist so
eine idee im postulat
aber er sagt es gibt es muss sie geben
die absoluten seiten darstellen
natürlich auch eine theologische
fragestellungen mit zusammen
das haben wir auch gesehen jetzt bei
leibnitz auf den wir auch noch kurz
jetzt nochmal zur wiederholung eingehen
werden die frage nach der also hier
dieser herr hier die frage nach der
absolut halt oder relativität der zeit
hat natürlich auch theologische
implikationen das ist ganz klar
also hat gott die zeit geschaffen ja man
kann sich natürlich ist auch so denkt
gott schuf die absolute zeit ist er kein
problem
bevor er sie schon das ist ja bei
augustinus so gewesen
gott ist selbst nicht in der zeit selbst
nicht zeitlich weil er die zeit erst
geschaffen hat genauso kann man dann
sagen gut die absolute zeit wurde selbst
geschaffen bevor sie geschaffen wurde
gab es nichts zeitlich ist also liegt
gott selbst nicht gezeigt es ist einfach
diese liste so eine kosmologische
vorstellung dass eine absolute ordnung
des zeitlichen ermöglicht wird und so
wie ich jetzt newton lese würde schon
sagen es gibt es gibt da so was wie die
absolut zeit gibt
[Musik]
die ereignisse selbst und ihre dauer
sind nur zur relativen zeit zu zählen
also wir können überhaupt nur ereignisse
in ihrer dauer messen und erkennen weil
es die absolute zeit gibt es also die
bedingung der möglichkeit von
zeitmessungen von einzelnen ereignissen
aber er wird das sagen diese bedingung
der möglichkeit die ist wirklich
existent die gibt es wirklich
da gibt es einfach ich habe mir das
überlegt wie so ein gefäß auch das und
gefäß in dem alles drin ist aber das
problem bei der vorstellung eines gefäß
ist es einfach das gefäß selbst ist
statisch vorgestellt gefäß selbst
verdient nicht er sagt aber die absolute
zeit verrinnt ja also wie sondern
vielleicht wie so ein permanenter
hintergrund der wie so ein zug also er
geht davon aus die die welt ist in
bewegung und diese grund tag nachdem
sich letztendlich alles bewegt auch wenn
es verschiedene spielerinnen kleineren
bewegungen gibt das wäre dann die
absolute zahl dieser absolute maßstab an
dem veränderung gemessen werden dieser
zug mit dem wir in die zukunft fahren
jetzt endlich diese große zug auf dem
sich alles dann abspielen kann
verschiedenes abspielen kann so
vielleicht sie hat eine dauer sich
verdient sagt dass sie vereint gleich
lesen
also ich glaube das haben in der letzten
stunde uns kurz erarbeitet ich glaube
dass man die absolut zeit am besten
dieser bereich vergleichen kann
diese absolute dort abfolge und gerade
seine perfekte gerade mit einer richtung
in der wir alles genau verordnen können
das ereignis war vergeben das von dem
und der zukunft bleiben diese
verhältnisse genau dieselben sie verrät
nicht schneller sie verrinnt immer nach
derselben taktik
und jetzt hatten wir dann in der letzten
sitzung noch uns mit leibniz beschäftigt
und leibnitz im hat eine gegenthese er
sagt eben was mich angeht so habe ich
mehr als einmal betont dass ich den raum
für etwas bloß relatives halte wie die
zeit zwar in ordnung des gleichzeitig
bestehenden wie die zeit eine ordnung
von aufeinanderfolgenden ist denn der
raum bezeichnet als ausdruck der
möglichkeit eine ordnung von dingen die
zur selben zeit existieren insofern sie
zusammen existieren ohne auf ihre
besonderen arten zu existieren
einzugehen und wenn man mehrere dinge
zusammen sieht so nimmt man diese
ordnung der dinge untereinander
es ist jetzt jede gegen gegensatz zur
absoluten zeit haben sie ideen als er
würde jetzt sagen es gibt keine absolute
zeit soll was ist die zeit
es ist jetzt auf jeden fall aus und
bieten auch ihren hellen genau dort
beliefert den absoluten aus und zeigt
wie man auch an den vielen konzerten ist
das ist mal ein kommentar von momentan
ansatz überhaupt fähig sind zu machen
beschreibt
genau hier braucht es als eine
grundannahme ohne prämie ohne diese
prämisse kann er seine physik nicht
konkret durchführen und hier ist es
jetzt bei leibnitz oder so wenn ich es
nicht falsch sehe zeit eher als etwas
anzieht was auftritt wenn gewisse
ordnungen existieren
aufeinander vor also für ein ereignis
von atp phänomen die zeit entsteht erst
dann wenn sich was tut und eine ordnung
sich verändert ich kann man sich kainz
kann man sich jetzt fragen setzt nicht
veränderungen schon zeit voraus müssen
wir um von veränderungen sprechen zu
können ich immer schon zeit voraussetzt
aber er scheint zeit ihr viel schwächer
zu sehen er sagte etwas bloß relatives
hält er sie die zeit ist eine ordnung
von aufeinanderfolgenden also da waren
ereignis und kommt noch in der s und
noch ein ereignis also erst in dieser
diesem zusammenspiel von verschiedenen
ereignissen tritt erst zeit auf und er
ist an dieser aufeinanderfolge trip zeit
auf das kann sich natürlich fragen kann
überhaupt etwas auf was anderes folgen
wenn es nicht wenn ich immer schon zeit
vorausgesetzt ich kann man sich das
vorstellen das ist mal ein bisschen
weiter noch mal was soll also der raum
ist lediglich eine ordnung der dinge und
die zeit ebenso und keineswegs eine
absolute wesenheit als er schreibt
newton zu dass er eine absolute
wesenheit wesenheit wäre jetzt unter
logisch gesehen schon etwas was
existiert ein ding im weitesten sinn da
ist etwas und das ist die absolute zeit
sie hatten gefragt ob es nicht nur so
eine voraussetzung ist seine prämisse
sie hätten gesagt zurecht newton sagt am
anfang das setzte einfach da setzt ja
voraus wird es muss er annehmen
aber er muss es wohl schon so annehmen
als ob es ist wirklich gibt nicht nur so
eine denk konstruktion jedenfalls liest
leibnitz international absolute wesen
halten
das problem von so einer absoluten
wesenheit derzeit ist natürlich die dass
wir uns sie schlägt dass wir sie
schlecht als solche erkennen können ja
oder ihren theologischen status genau
bestimmen können
da ist irgendwas so ein permanenter
hintergrund und das ist die absolute
zeit aber wie kann ich sie genau
erkennen da sagt leibnitz ich kann sie
nur an den konkreten dingen erkennen sie
ist auch nur anhand der konkreten dinge
existent und jetzt verklagt der gegend
klar ist ja der newton anhänger das raum
und zeit nicht die bloße ordnung von
mengen sind seien wirkliche mengen was
anordnung und lage nicht sind
leibnitz dagegen würde es sagen zurzeit
bestehen der größenordnung von mängeln
überlegen sie mal können wir durch die
ordnung von mengen die ordnung von
dingen so was wie zeit überhaupt
erklären oder plausibel machen
hier könnte man sich jetzt überlegen wie
man zeit re formulieren kann durch die
ordnung von mengen
also ich stellte sofort da haben wir
jetzt wir haben jetzt ein ereignis oder
was auch immer
1 und wir haben dann
wir haben dann ein anderes ereignis
wir haben ein ereignis und wir haben
irgendetwas was was da ist was sich uns
präsentiert und darauf haben wir ein
weiteres ereignis ein körper beliebige
andere ereignisse 3 und er würde jetzt
sagen dieses aufeinander folgen von
ereignissen das macht die zeit ist aus
das aber natürlich die frage kann
überhaupt etwas auf was anderes folgen
wenn noch nicht die zeit voraus gesetzt
wird kann man überhaupt davon sprechen
dass ein anderes ereignis auf ein
anderes volk ohne dass wir so was wie
diese diesen zeitstrahl dahinter haben
genau genau genau werden die bewegung da
ist was da ist was das wasser und die
frage ist können wir bewegung
analysieren können wir veränderungen
analysieren ohne auf den zeitbegriff
zurückgreifen zu müssen dass die
spannende frage also was mir eben
einfallen würde wäre zum beispiel so was
wie die logik wie eine logische
ableitung oder so wie ein logischer
prozess wenn sie jetzt zum beispiel aus
prämissen eine konklusion gewinnen oder
wenn sie eine mathematische aufgabe
lösen
dann machen sie das vielleicht empirisch
in der zeit
und wenn sie ein beweis geben wenn es
etwas beweisen
dann hat dieser beweis der verschiedene
logische schritt
eine genaue abfolge von logischen
schritten es gibt an den kürzesten
möglichen beweis einer bestimmten sache
den kürzesten beweisen oder in einem
schachspiel gibt es den kürzestmöglichen
zug um den anderen gegner schachmatt zu
setzen kann man ausrechnen
aber es muss eine bestimmte logik haben
es muss bestimmte abfolge von
ereignissen implizieren es damit aber
nicht gesagt dass dieses schachmatt
setzen jetzt in fünf minuten in 5
stunden geschehen muss es muss einfach
nur diese logischen schritte oder diese
züge nehmen als könnte man sich zum
beispiel sagen dass eben das eine
logische struktur die ordnung er spricht
der von ordnung der dinge dass die
ordnung der dinge
dass die nicht zeitlich gedacht werden
muss das würde es ja er will ja gerade
damit die zeit erklären sondern dass die
ordnung der dinge einfach relational
oder logisch zu sehen und da ist noch
überhaupt keine zeitliche ausdehnung mit
gedacht es muss einfach diese abfolge
haben aber eine abfolge die nicht
zeitlicher natur ist eine logische
abfolge wie man aus einer aus prämissen
zu einer konklusion kommt mir nicht
glauben sie nicht
es ist die frage ob man logik immer auch
zeitlich denken muss also es gibt
jedenfalls viele philosophen und für das
schon aber das wäre ja dann ihre
empirische sachen der eine braucht ein
bisschen länger die andere trägt die
konklusion schneller hin
aber was identisch bei allen richtigen
kommission wäre wäre dass diese schritte
gegangen werden müssen also dieses
verhältnis von logischen schritt wäre in
beiden fällen dasselbe einmal würde es
ein bisschen länger dauern man kann bis
so schneller genauso wie computer
bestimmt die algorithmen eben schneller
oder langsamer durch rechnen können
faktisch und faktisch schon aber der
idealen ordnung nach wenn wir nur auf
die nationalität schauen dann eben nicht
dann können wir sagen er ist muss dieser
schritt getan werden dann diese dann
dieser wald diese einzelnen schritt
erfolgen das ist eine andere frage
die frage ist eben dann ob man mit so
einer relationalen sicht der dinge einer
logischen sicht ob wir damit den effekt
der zeit erreichen können das meinen sie
vielleicht wir können natürlich daraus
nicht reduzieren
da sitzt der abstand ist eine logische
schritt vom anderen das dance eine dauer
von fünf minuten hat oder von zehn
minuten warum gerade diese bekommen
diese unterschiede ins spiel
er hat leighton ist glaube ich ein
problem damit lesen
ja ja also die frage ist guter punkt ob
die physik wirklich heutzutage noch so
was wie eine absolute zeit braucht oder
ob sie überhaupt diesen zeit verbraucht
oder ob sie nicht nur beträge von zeit
brauchen das hatten wir ja auch mal
geklärt also in der physik ist es ja so
zumindest als ich meinen leistungskurs
gemacht haben ich weiß nicht wie viel
jahren ging es nicht darum wie ich es
ereignis jetzt absolut gesehen früher
oder später war sind es ging darum dass
man einen zeitpunkt in die formel 1
setzt oder eine zeitdifferenz delta t
und mit diesem geld ht konnte man sich
bestimmte dinge aus regen dieses geld
hat ist die zeitdifferenz das einfach
der abstand von zwei zeitpunkten also
der praktisch größere - in kleineren
oder andersrum ist der betrag ist
einfach die zeitdifferenz und es ist
unerheblich für die zeitdifferenz wann
sie genommen wurde im absoluten
zeitstrafen die zeitdifferenz kann ich
wenn die abstände genau gleich sind kann
ich auch an einem anderen termin nehmen
es kommt einfach nur auf den betrag und
das meiden sie vielleicht wenn ich sie
recht haben also die physik gerechnet
braucht diese absolute zeit eigentlich
gar nicht konkret um ihre ergebnisse
sie braucht vielleicht als eine prämisse
bauzeit ist das mit zwei gleichzeitig
also gleich getaktet ist sozusagen aber
um zu ergebnissen zu kommen interessiert
mich nicht was absolut später oder
früher war es sei denn der kosmologie
der kosmologie oder wenn man dann so
urknall oder so physik betreibt dann ist
natürlich entscheidend wieviel
millisekunden oder was ich millionstel
sekunde nach dem urknall etwas war dann
interessiert die absolute zeit aber im
alltag wenn der physiker sich etwas
ausrechnet etwas bestimmen möchte eine
formel hat dann interessiert ihn nicht
die absolute position zeithstraße nur
die zeitdauer direkt
die den betrag einer zeitdauer delta t
jetzt könnte man sich überlegen ob mit
diesem was sie jetzt meinten mit diesem
delta t ob darin nicht nur auch seine
relational i tät gelegen ist die die
absolute zeit gar nicht braucht minuten
würde sagen doch wir brauchen die
absolute zeit weil nur sie garantiert
dass wir zu unterschiedlichen
zeitpunkten die zellen betrag der zeit
heraus greifen können nicht dass sie
plötzlich hier schneller verläuft können
wir hier gar nicht mehr denselben betrag
nehmen müssen voraussetzen dass wir hier
ein kontinuum haben sowie dem zeit mit
dem zahlen strahlen genau also dieser
zeit weil diese richtung derzeit ich
meine von der a3 derzeit mal ganz
abgesehen für die physik spielt keine
rolle
mit ausnahme der kosmologie vielleicht
also dieser urknall theorie aber
normalerweise spielt keine rolle was sie
zukünftig ist was vergangen ist was
gegenwärtig ist diese die die gegenwart
ist keine größe sehr flüssig und nicht
mal würde ich jetzt mal behaupten als
leise halber ley die absolute zeit und
die absolute position im zeit strömen
wieder mit ausnahme der kosten und
interessierte zeit differenzen
und die sind nicht bezogen auf konkrete
zeitpunkt im absoluten zeitstrahl sonst
einfach wenn ich jetzt diese formel habe
und eine lichtquelle fünf sekunden lang
photonen aussendet wie ich energie
betrag ist damit verbunden
diese lichtquelle kannte es zu jedem
beliebigen zeitpunkt tun ist
interessiert einfach die zeitliche
differenz dieser welt dieses delta t
diese zeit dauern
die ein bestimmtes ereignis hatte um
dann eben zu bestimmten ergebnis zu
kommen
aber interessiert nicht wann das
ereignis genauso zeit strahlen und man
sagt jetzt aber leibnitz dagegen da der
raum an sich wie die zeit nur eine der
vorstellung vorhandenen sache ist so
kann der raum außer der welt nur
eingebildet sein wie sogar die show
lastiger sehr wohl erkannt
der fall liegt ebenso mit dem leeren
raum in der welt den ich aus den
angegebenen gründen ebenfalls verein
gebildet alte also leibnitz zieht den
schluss dass
die zeit nicht mehr absolute wesenheit
ist es unterstellt ihre newton und an
die zeit ist zu dieser absolute
hintergrund dieses grundrauschen
gleichen takt sein grundtakt wie so ein
grund sie ich glaube sie müssen sich das
so vorstellen wie so ein metronom wie
ein metaphysisches mittag metronom was
regelmäßig zum takt angibt so vielleicht
ja zum gibt so ein codeteile
kontaktpunkt der welt und die ist
irgendwo da so eine größere ordnung und
jetzt sagt eben leibnitz nein die zeit
ist keine absolute wesenheit und daraus
folgt dann
sie ist meine vorstellung nur etwas
eingebildet ist unabhängig von den
konkreten ereignissen in der welt gibt
es keine zeit
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen
woher kommt dann die zeitliche
ausdehnung die zeitliche ja dir die
länge der zeit in verschiedenen
ereignissen kann man das aufgrund der
auf basis der reinen logik von
ereignissen kann man das daraus
reduzieren
also was die zeit erstrecken kann ich
das so wird die bloße logik von
ordnungen von relation kann ich
relationale kann ich damit ausdehnung
extension von zeit durch bloße
relational i tät oder mathematische
modelle so denkt ihr leben zu bleiben
das ist ein großer logiker alles logisch
bildung kann ich damit dieses phänomen
dimensioniert hat derzeit die
ausgestreckt haid wieder hinein gekommen
in unserer welt und da habe ich so meine
zweifel ob das geht
aber ich glaube nook die der logische
zugang will hier so glaube ich der
schlüssel zum verständnis und sagte noch
etwas zeit bewiesen habe dass die zeit
ohne dinge nichts anderes ist als eine
bloße nur an der vorstellung vorhandene
möglichkeit ohne die dinge ist sie
nichts
die frage ist jetzt natürlich was
leibnitz unter einem ding versteht
versteht oder ein ding ein ereignis oder
einem wirklichen gegenstand
und interessant ist auch noch dieses
argument hier
es heißt aus der zeit ein absolutes von
gott unabhängiges ding zu machen während
auch die zeit nur unter den gegenständen
der schöpfung koexistieren kann und nur
in der ordnung und der menge ihrer
veränderung zu begreifen ist
da kommt jetzt ein theologisches
argument spiel wenn die zeit absolut ist
ich sie dann einen von gott unabhängiges
team wirklich ich weiß nicht gut könnte
ja die absolute zeit schaffen haben wie
augustinus sa das finde ich ist nicht so
überzeugend was er jetzt sagt könnte ja
die absolute zeit geschaffen haben
das widerspricht ja nicht seine
mächtigkeit also für mich folgt das
jetzt nicht nicht da maßnahmen
dagegen sagt leibnitz während doch die
zeit nur unter den gegenständen der
schöpfung koexistieren kann und nur in
der ordnung und der menge ihrer
veränderungen zu begreifen ist das ist
weil ich die schlüsselstelle
ich meine das reine ist natürlich wie
wir die zeit erkennen können das ist
klar wir können zeit nur erkennen anhand
der veränderung aber heißt es schon dass
die zeit und theologisch in der
veränderung besteht ist ein unterschied
zu erkennen dass da was zeitig es ist
bei bewegung da ist klar kann man ja
sagen okay wir kennen nur die zeit das
derzeit ist weil es veränderungen gibt
es war ein ereignis wie 1
messi 23 aber das heißt ja noch nicht
dass die zeit auch unter logisch damit
nur so beschrieben ist
über veränderungen dann muss man sich
noch weiter fragen ist es nicht so dass
veränderung selbst begrifflich schonzeit
voraussetzt kann ich veränderungen
denken ohne dabei wieder zeit zugrunde
legen zu müssen nicht glaube ja wir
können es und mein kandidat war eben
eine logische folgerung aus prinzip und
da haben wir eben eine veränderung die
nicht zeitlich ist konkret natürlich
wenn jetzt da jemand eine logische
schlussfolgerung zieht dann ist es klar
dass es derzeit geschieht aber wenn ich
ausrechnen beweis dass es nur noch fünf
züge bis zum schach matt ist dann ist es
unerheblich wie lange ich für die züge
brauche ich kann einfach sagen ist für
schritte und zwar dieser schritt an
dieser schritt in diesen schritt ob ich
jetzt für jeden schritt zwei oder drei
stimmen braucht es egal
letztendlich ist es irrelevant aber es
gibt eine gewisse ein bisschen gewisse
verwaltungsstruktur innerhalb der
ereignis also und kann sagen dieses
ereignis ist auf dieses gerichtet und
dass es auf dieses ereignis gerichtet
und auf dieses auf diese ordnung die
ordnung sind in einer einem bezug
zueinander ob jetzt über diesen bezug
der ereignisse schon die zeit reinkommen
das ist die spannende frage
ich glaube es irgendwie nicht also mich
ich glaube nicht dass man zeit nur
biologische verwaltungsstrukturen wie es
leibnitz wohl hier glaubt zeigen zu
können erklären kann und rekonstruieren
kann ich glaube dass das zu schwach ist
dass wir dabei nicht die die ausdehnung
wirklich erreicht
wir können auch mit noch so viel
logischen schritte nicht so was die
extension die zeitdauer glaube ich
fassen das ist was ganz anderes
bin ich jetzt aus meiner sicht ihr bei
newton aber ist natürlich eine spannende
frage und also leibnitz ist hier könnte
man sagen so eine art ideal ist derzeit
ein idealist muss zeit ist nichts unter
logisches und zeit hängt mit dem dingen
ab und jetzt von den dingen ab und
letztendlich ist die absolut zeit meine
vorstellung deal uns existiert
jetzt gibt es hier noch so ein argument
einer schluss bevor bild einstellen
übergehen er sagt man hält mir entgegen
dass die zeit keine ordnung der
aufeinanderfolgenden dinge sein könne
weil die menge der zeit zu nehmen oder
abnehmen könnte während die ordnung des
aufeinanderfolgend dieselben bleiben
ich antworte dass das durchaus nicht zu
ist denn wenn die zeiten mehr ist so
wird es mehr gleichartige dazwischen
liegende zuständig geben wenn sie
weniger ist so wird es weniger davon
geben weil es überhaupt nichts näheres
gibt keine verdichtung und kein
hereinströmenden sozusagen in sich
derzeit zu wenig wie hinsichtlich der
ort
was ist jetzt hier sein argument mehr
zeit mehr ordnungs zustände derselben
art
also
[Applaus]
also irgendwie ist in der relation bls
die relation
und jetzt habe ich jetzt das wäre jetzt
eine kurze zeitdauer und dann kann ich
aber hier wieder so weit
vielleicht sogar auch nur so
ja
dann kann ich war dieselben dieselbe
relation hier eben noch mal dazwischen
schieben sagt also wenn ich mehr zeit
habe dann wird dieselbe relation
dieselbe ordnung eben häufiger
wiederholt habe ich die wiederholung
derselben relation
ich frage deshalb ob man damit so was
wie zeitlichkeit überhaupt erreichen
kann wenn ich dann mehr zwischen glieder
ein schiebe bekomme ich durch diese
logischen ordnung auch wenn es noch so
viele sind wenn sie noch so kompliziert
sind
wie komme ich da durch sowas wie
zeitlich ausgedehnt hyde ist die frage
mir fehlt da noch so ein schritt den
zwischenschritt aber das wollen wir
jetzt mal so
[Musik]
erst mal stehen lassen ja
ja also die abfolge von zwei ereignissen
oder in der relation zur b das ist halt
die frage ob das zeitlich ist also er
wird dir sagen wir können zeit nur
anhand von so einer relation zeigen also
zeit wird da nur erkennbar dass eine
ereignisarmen im ereignis bene relation
steht als das zum beispiel darauf folgt
wenn adolf b jetzt kann man sich eben
belegen wie kann ich jetzt auf diese
folge dass zb auf erfolg wie kann ich
das zeitlich denken wie sollte dadurch
zeitlich kein spiel vorne
also das ist ein sekunden über zwei
sekunden
so eine relation von ordnung erst adern
b
ohne zeit sich vorzustellen ergibt in
meinen augen nur eine logische folgerung
sb zb
aber wie viel später b oder wie viel
zeit das jetzt ausmacht das ist damit
nicht gesagt
also was soll das problem dass ich darin
sehr würde und wenn jetzt das argument
kommt ihr aber wenn jetzt viel zeit
vergeht dann würde er sagen gut dann
sind eben ist mehrere dieser logischen
relationen dann sind es eben die selben
logischen relation die numerisch
häufiger stattfinden
es ist so als ob es so hängt er wird
eben sagen es geht bis ins infiniti sie
male können wir eben zeit immer weiter
auflösen würde eher sagen wenn wir zeit
immer weiter auflösen kommen wir am ende
wird er sah zu logischen beziehung
logischen volk beziehungen wenn wir sie
bis ins allerletzte analysieren haben
wir am ende kein so muss man sich mal
vorstellen am ende kann keine kleinste
zeit größe sondern am ende bleibt
sondern logische ordnung wenn wir sie
immer weiter differenzieren
vielleicht kaufe ich meine kausalität
während beispielsweise kausalität wäre
für wäre jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt
zeitlich gleich zu denken sind einfach
eine ordnung hat das verursacht und so
stellt so reeh formuliere ich jetzt das
sagen würde wenn wir die zeit immer
weiter differenzieren den kleinsten zeit
betrag oder punkt haben wollen dann
können wir um überhaupt den grund
anzugeben dass jetzt zeit verschlossen
ist nur eine logische antwort geben
nämlich dass eben hier eine ursache im
spiel war und dass derzeit das zeit
verstreichen zurückzuführen ist auf eine
ursächlichkeit zum beispiel also muss
man konkret zu machen kann man sagen
hier
er ist kausalität oder ist die beziehung
der kausalität da ist die ursache
wirkung also wenn wir noch wenn wir den
allerkleinsten zeitpunkt finden wollen
die zeitdifferenz die die wir finden
können dann würde leibnitz sagen können
wir das nur deswegen tun weil wir sie
auf eine logische beziehung zurückführen
können nämlich der ursächlichkeit zum
beispiel aber mir stellt sich eben dann
die frage wie bekommen wir von blick
bekommen wir diese ursächlichkeit in
seinem sinne können wir sie zeitig
verstehen dass sich ausgedehnt ist wie
kommen wenn wir noch so fein analysieren
wie kommen wir am ende auf eine
ausgedehnt hat das ist eine spannende
frage
wenn der fahrer zu viel
vorher nachher geht hier hättest du weg
im leben sind gibt es alle aus dem ja
die frage ist halt nur ob wir um vorher
nachher sagen könnte ich schon die zeit
vor aussetzen müssen
so was wie eine absolut zeit voraussetzt
müssen wir auch noch eine relative zeit
der muss jetzt praktisch zeitlichkeit
ohne zeitliche technologie re
formulieren rekonstruieren können allein
durch die ordnung die relation ali-t von
ereignissen von dingen und an dieser
ordnung können wir erst die zeit
erkennen wurde er würde so weit gehen
sein kann erst die zeit auftreten die
zeit ist vielleicht mit modernen
terminologie reform derzeit scp phänomen
also die zeit ist etwas was auftritt als
mr giert vielleicht außerdem ergänzt von
logischen ordnung der relation wenn die
relation haben dann tritt die zeit auf
die zeit tritt an der ordnung auf und
nicht die ordnungs internetseiten
die frage ist halt wie wir davon davon
ausgehen dass eine ausdehnung der zeit
bekommen eine logische verhältnisse
ursache und wirkung sicherlich eine
ausdehnung haben als die frage ist ein
riesenthema wirkungen immer zeitlich
nach den ursachen sind gibt es eine
große debatte darüber sicherlich nicht
vor der ursache auch da gibt es manche
thesen die das sagen manche theoretiker
aber vielleicht gleichzeitig dass die
wirkung mit der ursache ein setzt aber
irgendwie ist doch die ursache vor der
wirkung anzusetzen ist mal überlegen
begrifflich begrifflich muss die die
wirkung nach der ursache kommen aber
dieses nach der ursache ist jetzt kein
richtig zeitliches kein richtig
zeitliches konzert es ist ein logisches
konzert in der ursächlichkeit steht das
etwas erst war und dann mal was anderes
und wenn ich es richtig verstehe möchte
er mit solchen logischen relationen
versuchen die zeit zu erklären
also wir bekommen die zeit dann ins
spiel wenn wir die logische folgerung
beziehen von ursache wirkung näher
betrachten um solchen relationen baut
sich dann die zeit auf ich glaube da
kann man diese kurzerhand das hat der
kapitäns problematik dass da irgendwie
form von ausgeht den teil drin ist die
aber jetzt nicht primär zeitlich ist so
logisch ist also logische ausdehnung
drin aber wir können wir die wirkliche
zeitliche ausdehnung rekonstruieren oder
aufbauen
auf basis solcher logischen aus den
zeiten als er würde wahrscheinlich sagen
so könnte man vielleicht auch sagen es
gibt so eine art logische zeit die
relationen die redaktionen wie zb
kausalität die nicht primär zeitig
wissen gut ich meine system ist also aus
erkenntnistheoretischen position ist
leib mit sicherlich näher an unserem
alltags verstand dass wir so gut wir
können nur erkennen dass da zeit
verschlossen ist weil sich da was bewegt
hat während sich nicht bewegen würde
wenn keine veränderung wäre dann könnten
wir zeit nicht erkennen
wir konnten der uhrzeiger bewegt sich
nicht wir können keine experimente
machen wenn wir etwas auf boden fallen
lassen das tut tut sich nichts wir
können gar keine bewegung herbeiführen
und da wäre leibnitz sicherlich recht zu
geben zu sagen da können wir dann zeit
nicht erkennen wenn es nicht die
möglichkeit der veränderung gibt von
ohren
dann haben wir kein
erkenntnistheoretischen zugang zu zahlen
aber könnte zeit nicht dennoch
existieren zuhause zu schließen dass
eben die zeit unabhängig von ordnungen
nicht existiert das ist eben glaube ich
doch noch weitergehender schluss den man
nicht ohne weiteres zutun kann aber
anhand der kausalität beziehung finde
ich hatte schon so ein gewisses argument
zeigen wir bekommen sondern so eine eine
richtung richtung bekommen wir auch
schon durch hoppla moment durch
durch durch logische relationen
kausalität hat ganz klar eine richtung
ahlen bmw bei la weist eine richtung
aber können wir diese richtung im
zeitlichen sinne irgendwann verstehen
dass die spannende fragen kann hier
setzt die forschung nach
also kanten macht letztendlich so eine
art synthese von newton und verleiten
kann zeigt die zeit und das entspricht
ist jetzt für von jud für leibnitz die
zeit ist nicht irgendwie unabhängig von
uns existierendes keine absolute
wesenheit darin folgt kant leibnitz
erfolgt aber gut an wenn er sagt die
zeit ist überall gleich sie ist eher
konstant und sie ist nicht auf basis von
bloßen folgerung beziehung von ordnungen
zu verstehen und sie machte das indem er
die zeit ist etwas was wir selbst was
wir als subjekte jetzt aber nicht als
empirische subjekt das dann als wir sagt
transzendentale es objekte als als
subjekte die sich die frage stellen wie
überhaupt etwas erkennen können dass wir
selbst die zeit ins spiel kommt dass wir
also die absolut zeit in unserer
subjektivität setzen und erst dadurch
zeitlich erfahrung machen können dass
wände dir eine chance form derzeit also
könnte es ziemlich genau eine synthese
aus leibnitz und ausloten bewahrt diese
realistische sage jetzt mal aspekt der
zeit dass zeit ein absolut ist und die
gleiche taktung hat er kommt aber im
leibniz insofern entgegen als er sagt
unabhängig von der subjektivität ist
zeit nicht existent sie ist keine
unabhängig von der erkennen
subjektivität existierende absolute
wesenheit zu wie die juden ist behauptet
hat
da kommen wir aber noch drauf in einer
der nächsten sitzungen darüber nächsten
oder übernächsten also ich glaube wir
haben jetzt hier gesehen wo die
schwierigkeiten liegen fast normal
zusammen also beim juden ist das problem
dass wir so was wie eine absolute zeit
schlecht erkennen können
wir müssen sagen es war eine forderung
postulat aber zusammen ist
existiert wirklich macht uns große
probleme wie existiert die absolute zeit
zum grundtakt und des universums oder so
ne b3 derzeit die absolut existiert und
anhand derer durch die wir erst kleinere
bewegungen messen können
newton sagt dass und leibnitz dagegen
sagten ja wir sollten hier skeptisch
sein
im endeffekt im zu beginn jetzt lese ist
zeit rekonstruierbar analysierbar durch
ordnungen von dingen von folgerung von
folge beziehungen aber diese folge
beziehung dürfen natürlich nicht
wiederum zeitlich gedacht werden das
wäre dann wirklich nutzen oder so cool
er ist also eher muss zeit
rekonstruieren re formulieren unabhängig
von zeitlichen begrifflichkeiten wie
vorher nachher und das könnte er
versuchen mit logischen beziehungen wie
zum beispiel ursächlichkeit und
wirkungen
da haben wir eine ganz klare richtung
drin wir können ursachen wirkungen
wahrscheinlich bestimmen ohne zeitliche
begriffe verwenden zu müssen also die
plötzlichkeit die qualitäts relation ist
eine logische relation und sie basiert
nicht auf der zeit könnte man sagen und
jetzt ist halt die große herausforderung
wir die ausgedehnt heid von zeit die
reale zeit einem durch analysen von
logischen beziehungen re formulieren
können also wenn wir immer kleinere
zeitpunkt zeit differenzen betrachten ob
wir am ende dann bei der logischen
beziehung landen und die zeit und es
unendlich viel logischer beziehungen
besteht und sich daraus konstituiert
oder ob er nicht doch irgendwie sowas
wie ne zeit einfach annehmen müssten die
dann mit logischen beziehung zu
vereinbaren ist aber die davon ab
würde dies bedeuten dass über 100 rubel
schnell
logisch entschlüsseln gibt das auch ohne
die zeitlichkeit alles gleichzeitig sein
können müsste wenn man sieht dass zum
beispiel eine pflanze nicht alle
chemischen abläufe gleichzeitig tun kann
um zu wachsen
widerlegt dass diese
ja es stand frage ich meine es blieb
einfach offen wie lange die pflanze
braucht für ihre abläufe aber das würde
wäre offen dabei aber das eben erst
dieser schritt kommt dann dieser dann
dieser dann diese also ich klar genauso
denkt er leidet offensichtlich aber die
frage ist halt wo kommt jetzt die
konkrete phänomenale zeit her oder diese
diese ausgedehnt hat diese reale zeit
würde ich sagen alles hat seine logik
ist muss er es dass kommen und dann das
sie dürfen nicht zugleich sein genau
oder so eine so eine folge zu folge
ja so eine nebenerscheinung genommen ein
gutes beispiel die pflanze um irgendwie
was tun zu können muss diese
verschiedenen prozesse durchlaufen und
das kann man sie jetzt mal ganz logisch
vorstelle ist muss das geschehen
photosynthese das und das und das und
das und das natürlich muss das nicht
immer zeitlich danach geschehen aber
davon abstrahieren wir jetzt bleibt uns
würde sagen wir können von der konkreten
zeitlichen nachfolge abstrahierende
interessiert uns nicht wie für sekunden
später das ist und wenn wir genau
hinschauen werden wir finden das eine
zeitlich ausdauer eine zeitliche
differenz im prozess eines lebewesens
zum beispiel dass das eben wieder näher
analysiert werden kann durch gewisse
relationen dann kam es an die täter so
nah und er bleibt das für das sagen am
ende landen wir bei logische reaktion so
lese ich jetzt am ende haben wir nicht
die zeit
am ende haben wir das warum oder ist das
und das wollen oder eben erfolgte
spazieren und nicht in eine zeit ein
ist eigentlich auch wiederum recht
plausibel weil wir die zeiteinheit ja
immer relational anhand von
verschiedenen ereignissen messen müssen
es gibt ein eigenes sondern ein eigenes
b und dadurch kommt er die zeit erst
zumindest der systemischen spiegel er
würde sagen sie haben die logik die uns
dieses diese ordnung gilt ja ist ein
schwieriges thema deswegen gehen wir
jetzt zum vielleicht drin vielleicht ein
thema also bleibt es einfach es geht mir
zu diesem netten kennt hier kennen sie
alle lassen dass man derzeit ein
bisschen heranreifen somit 15 jahren
ungefähr 12 und dann vielleicht mit 30
und dann so kennen sie hat seine
zeitreise gemacht und so kennen sie ihn
auch und ja jetzt wollen wir einfach mal
so ein bisschen auf basis der diskussion
um die absolute zeit uns mal mit der
relativen zeit beschäftigt aber jetzt
nicht relative zeit wie leibniz sie
versteht weil ja logisch zu verstehen
scheint wir wollen jetzt auf die und
logisches zeitverständnis eingehen also
nicht nur es theologisch und wirklich
wie die zeit wirklich ist aber eben ein
relatives und da gibt es eine wichtige
schrift von albert einstein
da war der gute herr ist 26 jahre alt
das müssen sich mal vorstellen 1905 das
war das so genannte anderes mirabilis
das wunderjahr diesem jahr
einstein unglaublich viele wichtige
beiträge verfasst und ein anderer
physiker nahmen zwei zähler hat einmal
gemeint
allein auf basis eines einzelnen aufsatz
hatte viele aufsetzen diesen geschrieben
hätte er jeweils den nobelpreis verdient
nicht nur für alle und er hat jemand
aufsatz geschrieben der hs zu elektro
dynamik bewegter körper und diesen
aufsatz den gibt's als als digitalisat
und ich habe ihn auf die lowcost mal
gestellt wenn sie diesmal auf die
lowcost punkt net gehen können sich den
gleich herunterladen
der ist natürlich zu schwierig für uns
um ihn hier zu behandeln aber es gibt
auf wikipedia eine sehr gute einen sehr
guten kommentar zu diesem aufsatz
also ich kann dir schick in den link
warum ist so eine art zeilen kommentar
also dieser aufsatz wird dann zerlegt er
verschiedene teile und er wird immer die
originalteile abgedruckt oder gibt es
einen kommentar dazu also wie man jetzt
diesen teil verstehen muss und wenn sie
das wollen können sie das mal selbst
versuchen sich zu erklären das ist mit
ein bisschen also war bei abitur wissen
physik und ableitung und so kann man da
schon ziemlich weit kommen
wir werden das jetzt aber hier nicht
machen das können sie gerne unabhängig
davon machen wir werden jetzt erst mal
ein paar leitfragen uns belegen nämlich
zuerst worin besteht der unterschied
zwischen der speziellen und der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie also die
spezielle relativitätstheorie hat albert
einstein im alter von 26 jahren 1905
eingeläutet und die spezielle ist eben
ein spezialfall da konnte er nur einen
bestimmten bereich der wirklichkeit
physikalisch modellieren und die
allgemeine hat er eben später dann erst
entwickelt 1916 also elf jahre später
hat ihn ganz viel zeit gekostet was ist
ein ideales bezugssystem welches sind
die beiden postulate der speziellen
relativitätstheorie
was versteht man unter dem
relativitätstheorie schicke ich ihn
herum und stellen uns dem auch als
internet welche paradoxen konsequenzen
hat die tatsache dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit überall gleich ist
welche konsequenzen hat die
relativitätstheorie für unser
verständnis von raum und zeit wie
verhält sich die relativitätstheorie zu
dem zeittraining bei newton und leibnitz
muss es richtig heißen und jetzt die
ganz spannende frage die mich fast am
meisten interessiert wie sollen
überhaupt philosophie und philosophen so
wie wir es sind überwiegend über
ergebnisse der modernen physik reden
ist das nicht eine anmaßung wenn wir
jetzt hier glauben wir könnten jetzt
hier irgendwas substanzielles über die
spezielle oder gar die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie es war
was meinen sie die frage möchte jetzt
mal an sie zurück studierte jemand von
ihnen physik einfach mal melden wenn sie
wenn es jemanden gibt der presse
studiert ok ich würde jetzt
interessieren zum beispiel wie
physikerinnen und physiker über uns
denkt wenn ich das jetzt eine physiker
einer physikerin erzähle
wir behandeln jetzt in diesem seminar
albert einsteins spezielle
relativitätstheorie in einer oder zwei
sitzungen die würden dann physiker
darauf reagieren was denken sie was
könnte jetzt eine physikerin sagen
aus dem was wir hier machen wollen aber
jetzt würde mich interessieren zu
welchen ergebnissen sie gelangt sie
bitte mal die physiker riege was sagen
sie zu den philosophen und will die
jetzt sich hier mit der speziellen
relativitätstheorie befassen wollen
ja
wenn ich jetzt
es sei ein
und ein guter wissenschaftler
größen wenn er wird okay wunderbar gibt
es weitere so optimistisch gestimmte
physiker ganz hin
weil wir haben
und nachher einig dass ein streit sagte
messen wir müssen dem staat rufen
indem
[Musik]
als er skeptisch wozu überhaupt damit
beschäftigen wenn am ende die rechnung
gemacht wenn es empirisch nicht relevant
ist diese überlegung meinen sie
ok vielen dank weitere skeptiker oder
vermissten bitte ok genau also gerade
noch mal was man ja bitte
zunächst war es hier nach also sollten
wir hier und heute die täter seien zum
beispiel werden genau bitte alle paten
gibt es ja noch erklärt ihr ergebnis
oder physik werden das jetzt offiziell
arbeiten wissenschaftler oder ergebnisse
zu denen die philosophen von sich aus
kamen neben physik haben spenden und was
weiß ich was anzuwenden
welches davon werde er erst los
kommen wir gleich zurückgeben als plenum
also quasi sich jetzt von bekannten
ergebnissen der von kölliker ausgeben
ohne dass sie sich selber quasi selber
auswirkungen haben
mit lion ist oder was nicht austrinken
blöd da war und ist ein mädchen
die küsten philosophen sind schon ab 4
ja die frage wer natürlich ob
philosophen und philosophinnen auf basis
ihrer profession überhaupt rechnen
also ich kenne nur ganz wenige
philosophen die wirklich rechnen also es
gibt vielleicht ein paar vielleicht
würden sie auch gar nicht sagen da sie
rechnen
es gibt hier dieses munich center von
mathematik und philosophie
da in der ludwigstraße und auch die
würde nicht sagen dass sie rechnen
sind sie würden sagen sie modellieren
also die tätigkeit auch von physikern
wäre weniger wahrscheinlich zu rechnen
selbst von physiker also für philosophen
wohl noch weniger aber selbst physiker
oder theoretische physiker würden sagen
wahrscheinlich wir rechnen gar nicht so
viel wir entwickeln modelle natürlich
muss er dazu ein bisschen rechnen
aber es gibt also auch fast so ein
bisschen so in die begriffliche arbeit
natürlich der angewandte
experimentalphysiker klar der muss
rechnete er muss uns ergebnisse bringt
der experimentalphysiker der
theoretischen muss natürlich auch
rechnen
aber ich würde es eher sagen dass es uns
modellieren geht von von von also von
systemen von erklärungsmodelle und auch
hier die die mathematischen philosophen
die werden wahrscheinlich in den
wenigsten fällen am ende so ein ergebnis
haben wollen wie fünf oder sieben oder
neun sondern eher so den adern b und a
ist geben dann ist sie würden eher mit
variablen arbeiten also ihr sollt es
eine logische arbeit machen als dass sie
wirklichkeit
aber gut als haben sehr viele
interessante stimmen bekommen und also
ich bin ich bin erstaunt dass sie so
positiv geblieben sind weil als ich mal
vor langer zeit nach dem abitur mich mit
einem physiker an physikstudenten
unterhalten hatte durch zufall meinte
ich also ich würde gerne philosophie
studieren und auch physik ich finde so
spannend zu diese diese fahrer nach dem
ersten letzten und da kann doch bestimmt
auch die physik ein bisschen was dazu
sagen so wohin gehen wer woher kommen
wir
manche diese physikstudent damals das
machen dann irritiert professorinnen und
professoren im alter von ich weiß nicht
wie viel jahren aber jedenfalls nachdem
sie nicht mehr im dienst sind das ist
die das machen dann mal physiker also
wenn es zu sagen ja ein bisschen
freizeit haben
dann beschäftigen sie sich mit solchen
fragen da war ich doch ein bisschen
enttäuscht weil ich eigentlich diese
fragen immer stellen mir stellen wollte
und dann habe ich mir da raus gesagt hat
dann studiere ich eben philosophie und
nicht für sie
wenn es die alternative ist viele ich
denke viele physiker würden das sehr
sehr skeptisch sehen wenn man sich als
philosoph das ist jetzt mit mit ihren
vermeintlich ihren themen
auseinandersetzt und dann glaubt darüber
noch was sagen zu können ich habe das so
ein bisschen jetzt ich hätte erwartet
dass sie das auch noch sagen aber dass
sie sind ja so positiv zum glück
eingestellt also ich hätte jetzt zb mir
noch vorstellen können dass dann in
physik studierte physik studenten sagt
also was bildet ihr euch eigentlich ein
hier darüber zu reden das ist doch eine
anmaßung
ihr könnt ja nicht mehr rechnen so ihr
könnt ja nicht mal hier
die banalsten newtonschen gesetze hier
erklären und jetzt mast ihr euch an hier
generelle aussagen über die spezielle
oder allgemeine relativitätstheorie
sagen zu wollen die auf einem
komplexität niveau oder ein generalität
eu angesiedelt sind dass das unsere weit
übersteigt sondern anmaßen also zumeist
mit zuwachs rechne ich jedenfalls stimmt
ich kann nicht
das sage aber ich glaube sie haben sind
gut auch daran haben guten guten grund
optimistisch zu sehen also stellen wir
uns jetzt mal hier ein einen
pessimistischen physiker vor eine
physikerin und wollen ihm oder ihr jetzt
einfach mal gute gründe dafür geben
warum wir das machen dürfen und sie
haben schon einige genannt und ich
möchte jetzt auch noch einen gegenüber
dieser skeptischen physikerin und dem
skeptischen physiker vorbringen nämlich
in historischen einwand dass ich sage
albert einstein hatte diese spezielle
relativitätstheorie wo deswegen
entwickeln können weil das wissen sie
vielleicht in einem philosophischen
zirkel unterwegs war hat also viele
arbeitskollegen gehabt auch philosophen
waren dann mit dem spiel und die haben
regelmäßig schriften von philosophen
gelesen zb von ernst machen
der war natürlich auch so ein halber
physiker aber er war auch ein philosoph
und nur durch philosophische gedanken
arbeit konnte albert einstein überhaupt
dieses modell dieses kühne modell
entwickeln um dann die konkreten
physikalischen erkenntnisse zu erzielen
also es ist glaube ich zu einfach gesagt
dass man nur mit mit einer
physikalischen ausbildung zu großen für
ihre physikalischen erkenntnissen kommt
sondern man muss sich immer inspirieren
lassen muss die gedankenfreiheit
besitzen um auch nach unerhörtes zu
denken
und da würde ebenso einem skeptischen
physiker sagen
das ermöglicht uns erst die philosophie
also diesen freiraum in gedanken zünden
kann ja
so wissen wonach man genauso ich denke
auch dass das den disziplin ehren
selbstverständnis der sich am ehesten
entsprechen
na also man entwickelt modelle und
schaut bewähren sie sich und das modell
hat solange geltung wie auch schon
gesagt würde bis es eben wieder liegt
das muss falsifiziert qualifikation ist
muss und dieses modell hat an sich kein
ontologische status modelle haben nur
dann eine geltung sofern sie empirische
fortschritte ermöglichen also der
maßstab ist nicht die logik des begriffs
der physik und der maßstab ist das
physikalisch in konkrete ergebnis des
messbare ergebnisse
und wenn wir uns davon entfernen von
diesem ideal dann kann man durchaus auch
sagen dass man dürfe sich bleibt aber
dann ist man eben ganz schön der
theoretischen physik und dann geht es
ganz schnell die philosophin ayn also
könnte man es sehen da gibt es natürlich
ganz viele ansichten darüber aber das
schalten wir jetzt eine der besten
antworten darauf zu sein
ok also jetzt haben wir so diesen
kritischen physiker die kritische
physikerin uns mal vergegenwärtigt und
jetzt haben wir uns ein paar motive
zurecht gelegt mit denen wir jetzt noch
in zehn minuten kurz beginnen können uns
mit der thematik zu beschäftigen
also es gibt ja ein ganz tolles buch und
zwar ist es im redline verlag in
deutscher übersetzung erschien kann ich
den c ans herz legen sich zu kaufen
kostet nur 5 euro
ich habe es natürlich auch ganz digital
also ich kann es auch in gänze
reinstellen
das ist die übersetzung eines englischen
bruchs revita welt schaut interaction
von russell steht und das ist ihm in der
oxford university press erschien ein
sehr guter verlag der beste
wissenschaftsverlag der welt und dann
kann das ja so schlecht nicht sein was
wir lesen und ich habe dieses buch mal
angeschaut und finde es sehr hilfreich
weil es in diesem buch diesem auto
gelingt ohne große vorkenntnisse
also rein basal die grundgedanken der
dieser speziellen und allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie dazu und das wollen
wir ja auch hier haben wir sind ein
bachelor seminar wir wollen uns rein auf
begrifflicher ebene diese implikationen
dieser theorie überlegen
also redline verlag sehen uns hier zu
empfehlen ich habe mir schon viele
dieser einführung angeschaut und es gibt
also viele auch im springer verlag und
ich weiß nicht wie viel es gibt aber
keine war so gut wie diese und jetzt
beginnt dieser standard mit folgendem
zitat also sollte dort alle wir alle
wachsen mit bestimmten grund
vorstellungen über raum zeit und materie
auf darunter den folgen und das würden
sie sicherlich auch teilen wir leben
alle im selben dreidimensionalen raum
das ist der absolute traum von dem
newton sprach die zeit vergeht für
jedermann gleich schnell
das ist auch eine newtonsche belegung
das ist die absolute zeit hat verläuft
schnell dauer ist absolut gleich zwei
ereignisse treten entweder gleichzeitig
auf ohne dass eine findet vor dem
anderen stadt
mit genügend antriebskraft gibt es keine
grenze für die geschwindigkeit einer
bewegung
klar geht immer schneller
1000 km pro stunde 2000 km 3000 km dann
10.000 pro sekunde 20 tausend kilometer
pro sekunde dann 300.000 km pro sekunde
und dann 400 tausend kilometer pro
sekunde und dann würde arbeit einstellt
sagen stopp das ist jetzt 100 tausend
kilometer pro sekunde zu schnell wir
können liegt bei 300.000 kilometer pro
sekunde übersteigen wir müssen ganz
knapp darunter bleiben geht nicht
schneller
schluss und dann müssen wir uns fragen
ja aber warum denn
also ist doch konter intuitiv ist doch
total logisch also wieso sollte es nun
möglich sein über 300.000 km pro sekunde
sich in einer geschwindigkeit vorzüglich
also warum 300 bar um die 400.000
kilometer warum
jedenfalls sagt die relativitätstheorie
es gibt eine grenze die geschwindigkeit
beiträgen normale dogmatische oder naive
von der physik jedenfalls gesehen
grundüberzeugung ist dass die materie
weder erzeugt noch zerstört werden kann
das auch so dieses energie erhaltungs
prinzipien dann die summe der winkel in
einem dreieck beträgt 180 grad
dass die klinische geometrie leuchtet
uns auch total ein und der kreis umfang
ist 2p x dem rathaus zwei pr und in
einem vakuum bewegt sich nicht immer
gerade dann würden sie wahrscheinlich
alle zustimmen erstmal ne ich auch
vor allem jetzt bezogen auf die zeit
vergeht jeder für jedermann gleich
schnell das ist die frage die uns am
meisten interessiert diese hier und sie
eine beitritt grundannahme wäre zum
beispiel die dass man sagt raum zeit und
geschwindigkeit sind unabhängige größen
diese größen haben nichts miteinander zu
tun
ja wir können geschwindigkeit natürlich
über verhältnisse von raum- oder von
strecke und zeit ausrechnen also
baugleich ist durch t aber sie hängen
nicht von einander ab ökologisch
unabhängig so und jetzt sei dass solche
vorstellungen scheinen wenig mehr als
gesunder menschenverstand zu sein
aber vorsicht das kommt den staat von
albert einstein der gesunde
menschenverstand ist die summe der
vorurteile die man bis zu seinem
achtzehnten lebensjahr angesammelt hat
also die berufung auf den gesunden
menschenverstand und da sieht man wieder
den philosophischen zug von einstellen
die ist eben nicht gut um zu neuen
erkenntnissen zu kommen und die
philosophie könnte man jedenfalls sagen
und damit hat man wieder ein argument
gegen die kritische physikerin den
kritischen physiker denen es ergeben
sollten uns jetzt einfach mal hier als
möglichen gegenpunkte wollen kann man
sagen ja das albert einstein fordert
eine kritik des gesunden
menschenverstandes
was hat nicht nochmal kant gesagt kant
hat gesagt aufklärung ist der ausgang
aus der selbstverschuldeten unmündigkeit
nichts anderes sagt albert einstein auch
wir müssen den gesunden menschenverstand
kritisieren wir sollten nicht so sehr an
bestimmte prinzipien glauben die über
jahrhunderte hinweg gang und gäbe war
die zum allgemeingut gehörten sondern
die philosophie und die physik eben auch
dann beginnt da interessant zu werden
und auch empirisch neue erkenntnisse
zutage zu fördern
wenn wir diese prinzipien
guten gründen infrage stellen skeptisch
seien kritisch sein
und das ist die philosophie die physik
vielleicht auch aber in erster linie ist
es die philosophie und jetzt gibt es
noch die übersicht die will ich noch
kurz gegeben also einsteins theorie hat
zwei teile einmal die spezielle
relativitätstheorie 1919 105 formuliert
war wurde dass es das andere swera biel
ist also das wunder jahr 1905 da hat
albert einstein so viele ergebnisse
publiziert dass er fünf nobelpreise
verdient hätte allein aufgrund jedes
einzelne ergebnisses hätte er einen
nobelpreis verdient in diesem jahr mit
26 jahren das ist schon beeindruckend
und dann noch die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie die elf jahre später
1916 erschienen erstere die spezielle
relativitätstheorie handelt von den
wirkungen gleichförmige bewegung auf
raum und zeit letztere die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie schließt zusätzlich
die wirkungen der beschleunigung und der
schwerkraft 1
erstere spezielle relativitätstheorie
ist ein sonderfall der allumfassenden
allgemein thüringen sagt ja schon den
begriff speziell ist ein sonderfall
die zeit um diesen bereich also mal
konkret so wir haben jetzt hier
dass unsere theorie gebäude und hier
haben wir jetzt die spezielle allgemein
spezielle relativitätstheorie ist und
das ganze hier ist die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie mit der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie können wir diesen
speziellen fall aus einer viel
allgemeineren perspektive noch erklären
jetzt natürlich die frage was ist die
spezielle relativitätstheorie was
wasserfallen gegenstands bereich hat die
spezielle relativitätstheorie
was waren gegenstands bereich hat die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie die
spezielle relativitätstheorie behandelt
die bewegungen in einem sozialsystem zu
müssen wir natürlich fragen was
sozialsystem ist dazu gibt es jetzt ein
beispiel das wollen wir noch am schluss
machen haben noch zwei minuten zeit
stellen sie sich vor sie befinden sich
in einem eisenbahnwaggon der an einem
bahnhof hält aus dem fenster sehen sie
einen zweiten zug denn neben ihrem zug
steht die pfeife ertönt und schließlich
setzten sie sich in bewegung
sanft gleiten sie an dem anderen zug
vorbei dessen letzter wagen verschwindet
aus ihrem blickfeld
also praktisch sofort ist das fenster
und dunhill vorbei was ihm ermöglicht zu
sehen wie der bahnhof als in der ferne
verschwindet
ob er zurückgelassen
nur dass der bahnhof eben nicht
verschwindet er bleibt einfach an seiner
alten stelle und bewegt sich nirgendwo
hin
genau wie es sie im zug sitzen und sich
nirgendwo hin bewegen
allmählich dämmert es ihnen dass sie
sich überhaupt nicht bewegt haben der
andere zog war ist der sich fortbewegt
hat das kennen sie alle
übrigens diese dieses problem stellt
sich auch mit blick auf die zeit also
mit blick auf die frage ob wir in der
zeit reiten ob wir als ob die zeit
bewegung nach vorne geht oder ob die
zeit durch uns hindurch läuft ob sie
auch in zukunft das ist eine ganz
ähnliche fragen stellt sie sich vor
haben jetzt alle gehabt und jetzt noch
ganz kurz zum initialen system das ist
eine simple beobachtung manchmal lassen
wir uns auf alle hat uns alle auf diese
weise täuschen in wahrheit können sie
nicht entscheiden ob sie sich wirklich
bewegen oder nicht zumindest dann nicht
wenn es sich um eine konstante
gleichförmige geradlinige bewegung an
normalerweise wenn sie etwa mit dem auto
reisen wissen sie dass sie sich bewegen
selbst wenn sie die augen geschlossen
haben können sie fühlen wie sie in
verschiedene richtungen gedrückt werden
wenn der wagen um kurven und über
schlaglöcher sind plötzlich beschleunigt
oder abreißen aber in einem flugzeug das
konstant dahin gleitet hätten sie
abgesehen von dem motorengeräusch und
den leichten vibrationen keine
möglichkeit zu entscheiden ob sie sich
bewegen oder nicht das leben innerhalb
des flugzeugs verläuft genau so als ob
das flugzeug auf der erde stehen
wir sagen dass das flugzeug ein
emotionales bezugssystem darstellt damit
meinen wir dass sich newtons trägheit
gesetz anwenden lässt das heißt dass ein
von diesen bezugssystem aus betrachtet
dagegen stand weder seine
geschwindigkeit noch seine richtung
ändern wird wenn keine unausgeglichene
kraft auf ihn wird beispielsweise bleibt
ein von ihren auf dem ablagerte
stehendes wasser glatt es an diesem ort
bis hier ist mit ihrer hand bewegen
ja
und es waren es noch das letzte zitat
lesen aber was geschieht wenn sie aus
dem flugzeugfenster blicken und sehen
wie die erde unter ihnen vorbei gleitet
sagt ihnen das nicht dass sich das
flugzeug bewegt nicht wirklich
schließlich ist die erde nicht stationär
es bewegt sich auf einer umlaufbahn um
die erde und die sonne die sonne selbst
befindet sich auf einer umlaufbahn um
das zentrum der milchstraße galaxie und
die milchstraße galaxie bewegt sich
innerhalb einer anhäufung von ähnlichen
galaxien
wir können nur sagen dass diese bewegung
alle relativ sind das flugzeug bewegt
sich relativ zur erde die erde bewegt
sich relativ zum flugzeug
es gibt keine möglichkeit zu entscheiden
wer tatsächlich unbewegt ist jeder der
sich gleichförmig relativ zu einem
ruhenden anderen bewegt ist berechtigt
sich selbst als rund und die andere
person als bewegt zu betrachten das ist
deshalb so weil die naturgesetze die
regeln die alle ereignisse regieren für
jeden der sich in konstanter
gleichförmige bewegung befindet das
heißt für jeden in einem internationalen
bezugssystem ist dieselbe das ist das
relativitätstheorie also kurz gesagt die
spezielle relativitätstheorie befasst
sich mit bewegungen im initialen
bezugssystem das heißt das sind
gleichförmige bewegung die nicht
beschleunigt sind keine beschleunigen
bewegung mit dem beschleunigen bewegung
fast sich allgemeine relativitätstheorie
wir befassen sie es nur mit
gleichförmigen bewegung und nicht mit
schneller werden bewegung und sofern wir
von gleichförmigen bewegung ausgehen
können wir jedes system gleichberechtigt
behandelt und das ist dieses relativität
beschleunigt bewegung geht dann spielt
die spezielle relativitätstheorie keine
rolle mehr substanz sondern müssen wir
eingreifen der theorie betrachten von
denen die gleich in der die
gleichförmige bewegung nur ein
sonderfall ist also so viel nur mal zum
anfang
ich stelle die folien rein dass sie die
auch noch man sich anschauen können es
gibt dann so ein paar schöne bildchen
hier noch
also hier so das beispiel eines bootes
was sich bewegte quellen oder gibt es
noch ein ganz tolles beispiel mit einem
raumschiff hier ein raumschiff wo eine
lichtquelle nach oben gesendet wird das
ist aus der sicht des raumschiffs selbst
das bewegt sich mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
einrichtung und das licht wird auch nach
oben geschossen im raumschiff und eine
lampe und dann haben sie verschiedene
betrachtungsweisen dann sehen sie das
selbe raumschiff mit diesem lichtstrahl
von außerhalb und dann sehen sie dass
ich darin was verändert und anhand
dieser veränderung können wir sie sehen
es gibt sich so ein dreieck hier und wir
können mit dem satz pythagoras können
wir und relativität effekt ausrechnen
anhand eines ganz einfachen gedanken
experiment eines raumschiffes in dem
eine taschenlampe einen lichtstrahl nach
oben sind und dann zwei
betrachtungsweisen drauf werfen und
anhand der konstanz der
lichtgeschwindigkeit die beide eben die
geschwindigkeit beide male genau
dieselben ist ergibt sich aber je nach
betrachter und perspektive eine andere
strecke die das licht zurück legt
nämlich einmal diese strecke innerhalb
des systems und einmal diese strecke
außerhalb des systems unterhaus folgt
die relativität und das wollen wir in
der nächsten sitzung uns genauer
anschauen